[Music]
welcome everyone
i am joy huang one of the view from top
student leaders
on behalf of our team thank you for
joining us today
we hope that you find this conversation
important and relevant
thank you joy so welcome everyone to
view from the top
today i have the pleasure of introducing
priscilla chan
the co-founder and the co-ceo of the
chan zuckerberg initiative
priscilla and her husband mark founded
czi in 2015
to leverage technology community
driven solutions and collaboration to
help solve some of the world's toughest
challenges
she is a physician an educator and a
philanthropist who
approaches philanthropy and indeed
everything with rigor
data and curiosity and really looking
forward to
learning more from priscilla and hearing
about what's on her mind the things she
is thinking about today in her
conversation with rex woodbury
nba 2021 so thank you again bristow for
joining us and really looking forward to
the discussion
priscilla thank you so much for being
here
it's good to be here here here virtually
uh well it's been an emotional week with
the chauvin trial with ongoing police
shootings with gun violence but
i want to say i've personally been so
inspired by the work
that you're doing at the chan zuckerberg
initiative on education and racial
equity
and criminal justice reform and i'm
thrilled to be having this conversation
and i know that my classmates are
thrilled to be here listening to you
today yeah
thanks for making up doing the work and
putting this together
um and i have to say in
this past week i i was just a
huge mixed bag of emotions like relief
um for the verdict uh
in the murder of george floyd and what
like in just like sadness that it had to
happen
that it happened this way and um but
also hope
always hope um that we're gonna do
better
yeah i mean i i want to talk
specifically in a little bit about some
of the initiatives that
you're working on which i think touch on
all of those
um you know aspects or values that you
just mentioned but
i do want to start with your family
because you have a very incredible
family story you're the daughter of
chinese vietnamese refugees your
grandparents were business people in
vietnam who
worked at canning pineapple and making
paper and running a restaurant
and i was wondering if you could share
with us the story of how your family
left vietnam and came to america
um so this happened before my time
um my grandparents were business
partners
um my um my
dad's parents um it had six kids
and my mom's parents had um
my mom's dad actually had two wives and
um a really interesting part of my
family history that's uh
that i just want to name is my mom's mom
was a second wife and she was
she was an indentured servant um who was
brought into the family to have more
kids
and so my uh between the mix of those
two
really um large and eclectic families
my grandparents were business partners
and when the war was getting
to be a pretty dark place um they
decided to smuggle their children out
and um they they were gonna become to
send their kids in boats
and in the united states they were known
as boat people but
the way they made their journey as boat
people was incredibly
um it's just real
um there were stories of boats
sinking and people dying on the boats
and so my grandparents decided that they
didn't want
a single boat to sink with all their
children so what they did
and and you know the unstated next step
is that they would lose all their
children
what they did is they paired up their
children into
twos or threes so that they would have
company
on the journey um but if any vote went
down they
they would only lose one to two children
and that's how my grandparents said
goodbye to their kids
on these little boats in the middle of
the night um
sending them off into the south china
sea in hopes that they'll see each other
again
and i hold on
obviously i wasn't there but i hold on
to that
image and sort of a moment of like how
big a decision um parents people make
for their
families for their livelihoods and
um the immense amount of optimism
that and faith that you have to have in
order to make that decision
um i i i i like to believe that that's
somehow genetic
and i've inherited it um
yeah but that's sort of what i always
come back to like
we there has to be better and we will
get there
um and then long story short um my
both everyone made it um and it took
about a decade for everyone to get back
together
uh but and then my parents
you know they stayed together for longer
than the boat ride and
here i am it's an
incredible story and you've said that
you know i'd love to hear if you're open
to speaking about those early
kind of years in i think it was suburban
you know massachusetts kind of outside
of the boston area
you know your family is building a home
there and and you've said that you were
bullied when you were younger and kind
of put your head down and
and worked really hard and then you know
got into harvard and
if you're open i'd love to hear about
you know how that early experience of
being bullied or growing up in that
environment shaped you and then
that transition moment i imagine it was
quite a
a shock going from that family life to
to the world of harvard when you were
18. yeah
so um we were sponsored at the time
uh refugees were sponsored um by
all different groups and the catholic
church played a really big role
um and we were sponsored by the catholic
church my family was and so we ended up
in an irish catholic town outside of
boston
and we were the first to arrive
and which otherwise was just like
straight up good will hunting
with like you know ben affleck and matt
damon as my neighbors
um so i did not fit in believe it or not
um and it was it
i um i
there's so many reasons why i didn't fit
in
but i remember
i remember thinking that i don't know
what's out there
but there has to be more and if i work
really hard i will get there
and i remember the day i made that
decision um
i was i was being bullied in middle
school middle school's awful
thank god we're all not in middle school
it really is it really is
yeah um and i was eating lunch in the
bathroom
in a public school bathroom because i
didn't want to go out to
um the playground um the blacktop after
after lunch and i was just like this
can't be the rest of my life right like
there's got to be more and so like i i
remember
as a sixth grader i was like i'm gonna
buckle down
i'm i don't know what's out there i'm
gonna work really hard and i'm gonna
get there um so
i i spent a lot of time chasing that
dream
and then i got into harvard which was a
little bit confusing because
um you know if my parents didn't go to
college
my parents didn't really speak english
and like
harvard was like an idea
but it was it was unclear how attainable
or unattainable it was
you know it was like hey we
we didn't have access to anything so
maybe this was just like
normal inaccessible not like sort of out
of this world inaccessible so like i
didn't know how to parse
the um the idea of going there or
or at least didn't get nervous enough in
time um
i got there and i was like
holy cow these people like
first of all like as an outsider going
to harvard everyone dresses the same
um everyone's wearing the same clothes
everyone's talking about the same places
and i've never been there and i
definitely don't i don't even know where
to get clothes that looked like that
and i was also no longer a big fish in a
little pond and i was
incredibly feeling like a failure
feeling like a fraud
and um the turning point
was realizing that i wasn't the only one
i joined the service house at harvard
where i was a part of the phillips
brooks house
and there were other people who
had stories like mine and there were
people and they were giving back and i
wanted to do that
too and that's been my mission ever
since um
but the most important thing that i
learned in that moment that i try to
hold on to always
is that if you hide you're powerless
if you hide in the bathroom if you hide
behind sort of who
you know who you think you should be you
are powerless
but if you name what's hard if you name
why you're different if you name your
story
that gives you power and so i've always
um try to be upfront about who i am and
sort of
name my experience name what i'm feeling
um because um when you when you
when you're not hiding you can be your
best self
and i'm not sure if it was when you were
at harvard or later when you were
volunteer or educator or doctor but you
talked
about a moment when you realized that
the problems were bigger
bigger than you bigger than you thought
that the structure in the system was
broken
and i think you know i'm sure that
resonates with a lot of our classmates
when
you step back and kind of realize that
you have to be
part of the solution or you have to get
involved and i'm curious can you talk
about when that moment
hit for you and how how formative that
was in realizing that
you actually needed to start a sort of
step one you know build the new system
or
or at least have a part in that yeah um
it's a terrifying moment um and
one where i will uh in the in the spirit
of naming
things is i failed um
i was taking care of an eight-year-old
little boy
in my practice at san francisco general
hospital
and i've been taking care of him for
like two or three years
and i was like there's some what's like
it was confusing because his mom kept
telling me he had seizures and i was
like i don't think he has seizures like
i looked everything up
he doesn't have seizures and i i kind of
like and then i was like maybe there's
something developmentally going wrong
and like with the school and i've been
trying to get in touch with the school
but the school hours somehow didn't
match up with my
um clinic hours and we couldn't get like
the only way to get information between
like the school and me was like a piece
of paper that we were having mom bring
back and forth
and so like we're kind of stuck like
this for a few years
and then i realized
he was eight that
there had been a giant miscommunication
that
mom had been telling the school that he
had a seizure disorder
and he had missed
he was eight so third grade by third
grade he had missed 180 days of school
which is one school year
because he the school had excused all
this before
his medical issue which was presumed to
be a seizure disorder
and they were doing they were trying to
do what was best for the kid
and meanwhile i was like no no seizure
disorder he should be in school
and um after we sort of like had an
emergency series of meetings we realized
that he had been witness to very severe
domestic violence at home and
he was acting out in a way that looked
like seizures
but weren't and so in
that series of miscommunications he had
missed
exactly what he needed a safe
environment that understood his needs
holistically
and instead he had missed a full year of
school and
he as an eight-year-old didn't know his
letters
couldn't read struggled with numbers and
when we tested him
he was of a normal intelligence like
big time fail and the teacher and
principal thought that they were doing
exactly the right thing and
for this kid i thought i was advocating
for the kid as someone who like always
asked about school how things were going
and so we had a collision
of people who were trying their best and
that the way we structure the way we
care for our most
vulnerable is completely broken and we
just completely missed the mark
and then i was like panic because i'm
like well i gotta tell someone
like someone needs to know that there's
a big problem and
i'm sure many of you like are very good
at you know identifying problems and
like
going to sort of going to the
authorities
the only problem is eventually you'll
find that there is no authority
and that no you're the grown-up in the
room or you're the only one who cares
enough about this problem to do
something about it
and and so i spent good six months i was
like if i do enough research i'll find
a way that this problem has been solved
or if i do enough this i'll find the
solution
and i realized that it just it didn't
exist
and um and when you confront that moment
you have to
think like what am i going to do about
it now
um and so that's sort of what
led me down the road of eventually um
starting the primary school
where we um i started a school in
a fit of insanity at the same time of
having a child and starting czi
um it's doing great now but they really
work on sort of
knitting changing the way the system
works knitting together
um health care especially especially
those
in our safety nets and um the school
environment
i mean what's so interesting to me about
your sort of two lives or multiple lives
here of
of being a doctor and you know some of
this is coming from my own my brother's
a doctor and i think
he and i talk a lot about depth of
impact versus breadth of impact
and you've spoken about what you said
you call it the trolley problem of you
know would you rather
help a hundred people deeply or you know
help everyone a little bit
and you know this will lead us i'm sure
into talking about czi but
i'm curious in your career as you evolve
through different
chapters how have you thought about
balancing depth of impact and breadth of
impact
i've gone through all different versions
of this um
and i think a couple things here
one is in order to make
the uh let's see which one are you
calling depth and breaths
is your is your brother taking care of a
single patient depth in your breath
like i would say i would say maybe this
resonates with some business school
classmates i would say my brother
subscribes to the philosophy
if he helps one patient very deeply in
his career
i think he views it as a success and
he's fulfilled
whereas i think you know somewhere along
the road and this is probably true of
many
gsb students you know we think much more
about breadth you know
let's scale this business let's grow the
system let's and i'm always telling my
brother i'm saying carson you know
think big you know fix the structural
issues of health care and
and maybe it's a different sort of
personal fulfillment of where you get
fulfillment from
um but i think i think of medicine as
depth of impact and maybe
business or fixing the structure as
breath
okay good um that's i have the same
definition
um but i will argue that you actually
not every person needs to do both people
naturally gravitate to one or another
but to really make change you need to
understand both
um and um
because in order to actually change the
you know
we'll take the change the system see you
need to actually
understand what the problems are and you
know what your brother
really unders what carson really really
understands
is what are the barriers that made it
hard for
this patient just to get to access care
or what made it hard for them to
remember to take their meds every day
like as a good doctor he knows that
and he has an intuition for it and
um it's oftentimes surprising um
the bus schedule used to determine and
whether or not the you know art was
running on time used to determine
whether or not my
patients would get to clinic and whether
or not my clinic would run smoothly
so it wasn't going to be some sort of
change management process in the way we
check patients in
it's like bart is screwing over my
clinic schedule
and so it's in i you have to understand
and have a clear vision
of what the actual issues are the real
barriers
that affect the lives of the people we
want to impact
in order to impact with brett um
and so at czi we hold that as a core
value
and we call it staying close to the work
we have to be proximate to understand
how to make systemic change um and
that's what
we we intentionally hire people with
both
and i can tell you that there are
disagreements and i'm sure we can name
many
and sort of just like language and
orientation barriers
around um when you bring such
different people of all different
backgrounds all different orientations
around the work to solve a problem
together
but that's when you actually understand
with clarity what you're trying to do
and um
like you then you can scale something
meaningful
something good in the world
but on a personal note i plan on going
back to a fellowship when i'm done
um with my my run at czi so
i am someone who loves loves being with
kids and families i still i i mentor
kids
little kids over a zoom and at the
school i love that
i need that to nourish my soul but i
have to say this
systemic work is what gives me hope um
and that's why a lot of um you know to
use your brother again as an example you
like it's amazing being on the front
lines and that's incredibly gratifying
but if you run into the same problem for
the hundredth
or thousandth time you can lose hope and
so
it's the work and changing the systems
that gives me hope
in that work well it's good to know that
you can have
you can do both you can have different
chapters and reinvent yourself and
in different chapters of life and career
but i do want to talk about the systemic
stuff and and czi specifically the chan
zuckerberg initiative
i've heard you say that you know i think
you started it the same year that you
had your daughter max
and uh i've heard you say being a new
parent and starting a philanthropic
organization are similar so i'm curious
what you mean by that
oh man um uh uh
keep you up at night um it's lots of
sleepless nights for different reasons
it's either the baby or uh or building
an organization
and i think the core of it though is
what i mean is
when you guys all go out there and
contribute to organizations of
all different phases um and stages
it's i'll use a pediatrician term is
like
is it developmentally appropriate um
and uh you talk to people
all organizations have sort of goofy
things about them
and things that they're working through
and
but some problems are developmentally
appropriate for the stage of the
organization
and some aren't um and
uh when you when you're you know up at
night wondering like
is max okay like is she she's smiling
and you're googling like for the parents
in the room like you're googling like
smiling at five weeks okay like
there's a similar version of what
happens when you build an organization
like
is it okay that like we you know there
are
moments at cci where we had our internet
cut off
because we forgot to pay the internet
bill um
and that was okay at like week eight
but it is not okay at year five and so
um i think just understanding sort of
the cadence and evolution
and growth of an organization and
giving yourself some slack
when you're like oh it's okay this is
like this is a problem that many
organizations have we'll get to it
and like solving the right ones at the
right moment in time
for the organization and you stepped
away from medicine to run
to be co-ceo of czi and
i think one journalist wrote about you
she's a doctor that has become a
crusader
and i'm curious what is a trait from
your medicine days that you've carried
with you that's
been surprisingly helpful in running czi
and what's what's sort of something
you've had to learn that knew
um let's see i
um love being a student um so i don't
know if that's a crusader but i will
trade seats and just soak in knowledge
at any moment
um but i think
the same thing that brought me to
education to medicine and now to cci
is that these are people's lives
we're touching um and
there's a you know you can track metrics
you can think about sort of um
sort of dollars and impact
and um
all different ways that you can quantify
but at the end of the day
um we're touching people's lives and
people's lives are complex um
they uh we need to see the whole picture
um and we can't forget that
and when i think about
this the patient that i told just told
you about
or many of i have many a catalog of
faces that's sort of like
it's get me going better than coffee
every morning um
i um i can't stop
because i have to do better
and um there's no there's no choice to
give up
i can fail and i fail all the time
but i can't stop because
it's not an intellectual idea
that i'm pursuing i'm trying to actually
touch and change
people's lives at the end of my time and
so
um quitting's not really an option
um let's see things that i learned new
um oh i could like honestly
at one point i was like i should go to
business school i don't know anything
about i'm like what is hr because
remember i think there's some a few mds
in the room
like hr nobody's ever cared about me
nobody's ever told me
like that like like you know i've been
yelled at in the middle like
like there are people that are supposed
to take care of me that's cool
so learning about hr learning about
operational management
gantt charts are a thing like and make
things run smoothly i think
i'm just saying words that i've heard
that now other people help me do
um but you know being a smart about the
way
um you prioritize run projects
and get people convince people that you
have a mission worth pursuing
i think we're seeing this bleeding i
mean social impact business
at stanford you know our social
innovation is important to a lot of
students and it's a big focus of their
curriculum
but i think we're seeing bleeding lines
between the two and i was really moved
by your
letter to your grant partners from a
couple weeks back about the attacks on
asian americans
and how it personally resonated with you
and your grandparents story
i'm curious if you could speak about you
know what that emotional
um you know time for you but also from a
business perspective what are ways that
leaders can
can get involved and can take issues and
actions on on those different problems
yeah i have to i have to be honest um
i had to take a step back and do some
learning and reflection
when this all happened because
in sort of my experience
growing up in a uh
one of the only um asian american
families
in our community and then going to
harvard where you know
being really involved in social justice
and often in our country that's about
black and latinx and the historically
underserved
populations i i
that's been my calling and i relate
because i'm like i get it i'm an
immigrant
i've been an outsider like i identify
with the issues that you face
and i've never until recently never
really taken a moment to reflect on my
my own racial identity um because i
i sort of just always assumed one that
it was an anomaly
um and two
um and this is probably the result of
being
raised by refugees just put your head
down
it's going to be fine like just take
what you can get
and like keep going and you'll be fine
and the interesting impact is it made it
easier for me to advocate for others
than it was to advocate for myself
and this is not a new phenomenon um it's
well studied and well documented that
also like for instance women can
advocate very well
for other women and struggle with
advocating for themselves
and um the
so i did some reflection there's a five
part pbs series that's excellent
on called asian americans um i highly
recommend it
and starting to really think about like
how to to make sure that we're not
always forgetting the asian america the
aapi community when we talk about people
of color
because they are people of color that
have
very complex relationships with race
and other uh in their own race
other minorities in our country and
um and we we need to examine it
collectively and i have to say i've
spoken to
many asian american leaders in the wake
of the shootings
and they it's a very similar story
they're like oh yeah i gotta wake up to
this
and so i would say for others in the
business community is understanding like
we
like do some learning um
and um also
think about how um
just because a group doesn't speak up
doesn't mean that there
aren't needs um because this is a group
that's
historically in our country um
for one reason or another um
not trained to speak up for many reasons
priscilla i have one more question for
you before we hear from two students
and i want to go back to your
grandparents and parents coming to
america
on the boat from saigon and you know
you've spoken about them you've spoken
about
your own kids what's one important
lesson you know if you had to pick one
lesson that your parents
grandparents that you've taken from them
that you want to teach your own kids
what would that be
um so
the optimism that i was joking i hope
it's in me
i um i want them to feel
um that optimism too and
not a pollyanna type of optimism but
a faith
that people will continue like things
will
if we work hard and we continue the
fight things will improve
um and to always believe that there has
to be better
um gratitude and this one's gonna be
you know i grew up
as a child of people who were uh
politically persecuted refugees on boats
just like just grateful for every day
um and the last one is um
sometimes for many reasons not seen as a
very popular
sentiment but i love our country
and you know it's popular to you know
sometimes like
one side of the political spectrum gets
to love our country
or you know there's so many things
broken that
you know how can you love the united
states of america
we have it's this this country is
founded on strong ideals that are not
perfect
but it is our responsibility to build a
better country
and if you don't love it and you don't
nourish it it cannot live up to its
potential
gosh i didn't realize i was so patriotic
until just now
that's great thank you well i i do have
actually one more i know i said that was
last one i have one more question for
you but first we're going to hear from
two of our students and i want to make
sure
we have time for them i think first up
is jessica so we'll hear from jessica
now
hi priscilla thanks for being here today
and sharing your wisdom with all of us
um my question is around the huge health
disparities we've seen especially during
this pandemic
now as a doctor and as a philanthropist
how do you think
we can solve for the health inequities
in this country
i think it is important to realize that
related to the sort of understand the
problem that you're trying to solve
is that everyone has different barriers
and there's not a one size fits all
and there we have to take a community
centric approach to addressing health
disparities
um we uh we
very early on in covid we ran a study on
the prevalence of coronavirus in one
census tract
in the mission and what we realized
um diane hadler did this and
from ucsf is that in this one census
tract
zero people of caucasian descent had
coronavirus
and um i think it was near 20
of individuals with a latinx background
had coronavirus
during this period that they were doing
the test and
uh first of all that naming the
disparity that you named
and the two groups had different access
and different barriers to actually
accessing testing and accessing care and
um what that group then did was partner
with
the community they partnered with the
latino task force and said look
what is the best way to get tested what
is the best way to follow up um
and under and because it was such a deep
partnership
the testing and treatment and now
vaccination of that community
is incredibly strong and we sort of
spread those learnings across the city
but you know the same thing that would
have worked for honestly i had a
colleague who fell into the census track
who would have worked for david doesn't
work for someone else
um who has an entirely said different
set of life circumstances
and so um it's not about scaling
what work sometimes can work for uri
it's about working deeply with the
community to understand like
name help us name the solution together
thank you thank you jessica
next we have a question from mary grace
hi priscilla my name is mary grace
reeves i'm in my fifth year of
stanford's dual mdmba program
and i'm looking forward to starting
residency this summer and it's such a
privilege to hear you speak
thank you for being with us i'm
wondering in founding
and leading the chan zuckerberg
initiative you're tackling the most
pressing societal challenges
of our time and through that process
what have you learned
about building a successful team and how
has that allowed your team at czi to
navigate diverse initiatives
you know building i think building a
good team
is sort of it's it's i i wouldn't say
it's specific to our work at
uh czi but it's
naming things being clear about what
problem you're trying to solve
prioritizing it and being really direct
with other people
um when things are working or when
they're not working
um and i will i will name i followed
into the same traps like
uh i don't want to say it it like might
hurt their feelings
i don't want to be mean and you know i
realized along the way like
look i am who i am but like
they're and they're gonna like me or
they're not but
like i do know that people like
to be successful and the way i make them
successful
is i tell them i'm as clear as i can
with what i want to see and what
feedback i have
and so um
that's that's that's i i have to say not
specific to our work at cci but just
like
say it like it is mary grace thank you
thank you mary grace we're still i have
one last question for you which is
actually a question that we're asking to
all of our speakers this year
and it is what are the principles that
you rely on
when you're facing the toughest moments
as a leader
um in my toughest moments
i like those the pictures of the kids
that
i've served and i've had successes and
failures with i keep them
in my mind um and i remember
that i remember those lessons like
i have to like how would i solve this
problem
for him or for her um
and like build up from the community
like i was just say uh
saying earlier like try to understand
the context
that people's lives are in and solve
from there
um and that collaboration is key
um not one person has
understands the solution fully and not
one person can see
uh not one person no one sees the
problem and no one sees the whole
solution but if we come together
with different tools different skill
sets we can solve this together
um and
that's those are the two bits and that
if this is
also it's a lot it's a lifetime of work
and so you got to break it down into
little pieces and
um like uh
the only way to eat an elephant is one
bite at a time
i can't say i've heard that phrase but
that's what i'm gonna take away i didn't
invent that
okay that's either desmond tutu or
that well thank you so much i think i
speak for everyone when
you know we're inspired by your story by
what you're doing at chan zuckerberg by
um you know the different lives and
chapters that you've had and how you
live
um with values and with those principles
so
thank you so much for your time we hope
to have you back hopefully in person
one time soon um but thank you for
joining us virtually
yeah thanks for having me next year in
[Music]
person
you